台股歷史第三大跌點
為什麼那麼恐怖啊
跌在一兩千點
因為蘋果最新的筆電
一台漲價十萬元
你買得下去嗎
真的還假的
十萬元不誇張
平板啊
平均漲個七千元
甚至一萬元以上啊
這樣怎麼買得下去
會不會造成
記憶體太貴
反而壓死台股
為什麼呢
這跟景氣有什麼關係
我今天要獨家告訴你三大重點
第一個
蘋果大漲價
股價
跌6%
漲價是說產品漲價
股價跌60%破底
還會破嗎
會不會影響這些蘋概股
鴻海這些老AI
第二個
記憶體飆翻天
會不會引發通貨膨脹
讓費德升息
讓股市崩盤
台灣股市會不會跌破4萬點
今天獨家的解讀
很多人根本不知道
今天台灣股市為什麼跌
我獨家的邏輯以及理論
告訴你這一切
你今天不看
真的很可惜
真的會很可惜
好不好
台股今天大跌快1700点
你害怕了吗
很多投资朋友们都很紧张
就像刚刚投资长说的
主要的原因就是美股昨晚
受到苹果大跌6%的影响
而且今天韩股也大跌超过8%
又大跌熔断了
台股想要独善其身
确实有点难度
在多头市场当中
还涨急跌是很正常的
想知道今天投资长
对于突如其来的沙盘
是怎么看的吗
蘋果的筆電平板究竟為什麼要大幅漲價
趁著周年慶投資長又會買進哪些股票呢
接下來就交給我們經濟日報選股冠軍紀錄保持者
同時也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
最受歡迎的分析師
郭哲榮投資長
投資長好
李李 各位投資長大家好
哇 這個今天的股市真的很刺激
外行看熱鬧 內行看門道
如果看我節目一點點
哪有喜歡吐槽我一定說
哲哲 你昨天不是說台灣股市今天要暴漲
今天要上漲
那前提是美國股市不能跌啊
是
沒有人知道說昨天蘋果
就是Apple啊
產品線全面給你漲價
是
沒有人預測到啦
我有預測到
但我不知道它漲那麼貴啦
那當然會引發怎麼樣
會不會科技通膨
是
壓垮
科技股
這是獨家的喔
今天你聽其他人去講那些
其他的邏輯那都是不對的
好不好那都是不對的
基本上你會發現到
就是哲哲講這些最全面
你今天一定要看我的節目
看了以後你就知道哲哲總體經濟面
消費行為心理全面跟股市
我是Top 1
我是Top 1 好不好
我們福利社當然
哲哲福利社也有身兼製作人之一
也有提供這樣的意見
不然你看不到這麼精彩的一個邏輯
我們可以講結論
今天空單8萬口變成7萬6
壓垮台股
這不是 我之前講過這是什麼
這是一個怎麼樣
這是一個應該說套利的行為
第二個
哇 韓國股是大跌
台灣股是跟著跌
這叫廢話
韓國股是怎麼跌
因為美國股是跌
這叫廢話
因為蘋果股價跌
這個有點廢話也不是廢話
那為什麼蘋果股價跌
漲價
為什麼漲價會連動影響AI股
這才是我獨一無二的邏輯
我直接跟大家講好了
我們先慢慢講這東西
來看一下
先開始來看這東西
基本上在這種情況之前
去看技術線形已經沒有用了
折折 月線跌破怎麼看
這一波都沒有跌破月線
月線是買點
或許是
也或許不是 什麼意思
當即時如果真的是一個大通膨開始的時候
你說台灣股市有沒有可能回來
一萬點 兩萬點
這都有可能的
我今天要探討的是
它會不會影響一個全面性的通膨
是
我告訴你答案
所以在這個時候
技術線型已經沒有什麼意義了
你技術線型是有點落後指標了
你要記住這件事情
一定要技術線型加基本面加籌碼面
你才能決定你的股市的完到
你來告訴你方向哪邊走
聽不懂沒關係
我不像有些寫Trade的文章
或有些影片
似是而非
我都告訴你答案
今天我們來慢慢看
先講這三大重點
蘋果大漲價
因為就是產品大漲價
股價跌破
跌6%破底
不好意思
你看蘋果走勢圖
這樣跌6% 很慘
蘋果耶
就像台積電跌6%一樣
為什麼 它亂漲價啊
趁機體漲價它還漲很兇啊
你看蘋果的走勢圖很恐怖
有沒有看到
月線 台股的桿跌破月線
它連季線都跌破有沒有看到
是的
這個是典型的
ABC反彈 下殺 波
當然我要告訴大家技術線型不好看
但是最重要的是基本面
我們來看一下
為什麼漲價它會被殺成這樣子
來你們看一下
Mac mini有沒有看到
有沒有看到
從19,900變26,900
你比較沒感覺
很多人比較少人會買這個
會買13吋的iPad Pro吧
會不會
有沒有看到
來看一下
從32,900變快4萬塊
LiDi妳會想買嗎
好像有點貴
長得有點多
是
所以我告訴妳
以後手機大概也差不多
7000到1萬塊
真的嗎
好不好
差不多
我認為至少
就這個幅度
大概都差不多
差不多就大概增加個
差不多
到200多美元啦
大概200多美元
大概7000塊
你看這個定價就會知道了啦
好不好
你看定價就知道了
就是你原本譬如說
所以你趕快到這邊
到時候今年是16嘛對不對
是不是
是
不是去年是16嘛
去年
今年要生產17是不是
18 對不起
不專業
不是我每年都有換嘛
反正就是去年的新
去年的17嘛對不對
就今年還在賣17嘛對不對
趕快買喔
到時候17買不到
又變貴了
不是到時候你要買
全部買18
除非你要買折疊機啊
我是跟你講喔
你想要換新
想要覺得iPhone跑不動
趕快買那個17嘛對不對
就是趕快買這個
上半年還買不到手機
去年發表的手機
趕快買一買好不好
先跟你講
好你看喔
為什麼
這個一件事情
你解釋的是喔
當產品那麼貴的時候
會不會影響到蘋果的銷量
會不會啊
會
一定會啊
那好 影響蘋果的銷量
你不是說我漲價就好
什麼東西漲價就好
不知道我就不想買啊
是不是
我很多人 我是可以買
我是不在乎的
可是我身邊大概100個裡面
90幾個人應該不想買
小孩不想買嘛對不對
不想買嘛
所以週期 換手機的週期
可能從4年到5年以上
那就會影響到銷量了
那影響銷量的時候
是能吸收這個衝擊
第一個 你蘋果賣那麼貴
我管你是不是機體
就消費者而言
我管你是不是機體很貴啊
我不能量解 我反正我不想買啊
我沒漲價啊
很多人說是台灣K型經濟啊
有買股票的像帝王啊
沒買股票的像平民一樣啊
什麼都不是啊
是
的確是這樣子啊
有買股票的人可能還買得起
漲價的iPhone
可是他還不一定想買啊
沒買股票的人
他漲價的iPhone他連買都不想買啊
所以造成iPhone的消...
iPhone啊還有
iPhone還要
iPhone是在佔它主要營收
平板的銷售量
iPhone還沒公佈喔
甚至iPhone的銷售量會下滑
会造成红海的营收
造成那个苹果营收下滑
那我问你
会不会造成红海营收下滑
会
会啊 红海
苹果是红海
那个
苹果是红海最大的客户
以前营收占60%
现在压到40%了
还是他大客户啊
所以红海股价今天就跌3%
这个你看到
是不是首先影响到红
苹果就影响到红海
影响到红海会不会影响到台股
会
全职股第四代多少
有影响到台股吗
好啦
那会不会影响台积电
也是一樣啊
台積
蘋果以前也是台積電最大客戶啊
你懂嗎
那我現在
我漲價是因為
為什麼我漲價
因為你們都需要
那哪一天蘋果不需要的時候怎麼辦
我就賣不好嘛
是
那我就賣不好
這個就知道我AI可以漲價
但我一般的
AI是B2B的
Business to business
就什麼意思
就是我
我公司對公司了
那我公司對一般銷售客戶呢
Business to什麼
Cust
那個customer
consumer
這幾塊呢
你又怎麼辦
B2C怎麼辦
一般企業到消費者的賣不好啊
你AI這一塊我賣得很好
可是我B2C這一塊賣不好
那市場上還在吸收這個衝擊
是
在吸收衝擊的時候怎麼辦
先賣再說
因為算不太出來
很難算你懂得懂
對啦
現在是AI這玩意到來
AI產品佔的營收越來越高
但以前老舊這一塊
手機這一塊
可能以後賣不好
會不會減少營收
一個加營收
一個減少營收
怎麼辦
都是記憶體能的貨
所以今天記憶體能的貨
大家就怪到記憶體
但記憶體能的貨怎麼樣
就記憶體殺很兇
因為長期而言
對記憶體也不好
通過講什麼
蘋果大跌
很多說蘋果大跌
所以影響美股
所以影響台股
這是最low的解法
重點是為什麼蘋果大跌
因為東西賣不出去
應該說賣的會賣的差
賣不出去會影響鴻海
會多少影響台積電的
溢價能力
好
這次我要講的還有什麼
如果
那好
蘋果會不會影響那個
納斯達克
會
蘋果會不會影響納斯達克
也會啊
影響這些納斯達克的指數
這些相關的
這些全值股啊
還有什麼
蘋果
還有一件事
假設我記憶體啊
假設我簡單簡化啦
我本來要漲價
因為我記憶體
我就是貴嘛
你要不要吸收你的事情啊
我海力士
我三星賣你蘋果怎麼樣
賣你一年假設賣你九千萬條
九千萬條的記憶體
假設我很簡單化
那我現在因為銷售量不好
蘋果手機平板到時候因為漲價銷售量不好
變成七千萬條
那我多出來兩千萬條的記憶體怎麼辦
還給你們這些怎麼樣
三星海力士啊
然後還給你這些記憶體產商
還給你這些鎂光啊
那怎麼辦
那這些多出來的
原本預期可以賣得掉的記憶體
那你又回去原本的市場了
沒錯吧
因為我蘋果賣不掉嘛
對
那我問你那這邊多出來的記憶體怎麼樣
會不會變性的殺價
JDDR4
他之前HBM這一塊
就AI記憶體這一塊
回來做記憶體是因為
記憶體毛利太高90%
那現在如果我這些記憶體賣不掉
有些部分賣不掉
其他地方賣得掉嗎
你聽懂嗎
我蘋果我銷售量下滑
讓我記憶體
在蘋果這一塊
是不是記憶體不需要那麼多了
對
那大家就考慮那記憶體會不會到時候
有降價行情
還是不會
因為AI需求更大嘛
是
那到底AI需求大到
像AI這個
記憶體好玩的是不是這樣子喔
不是價格跌才會跌喔
而是價格可能不漲了也會跌喔
你聽懂嗎
真的喔
就像航運股一樣
你懂不懂
領先的報價
報價漲的幅度不夠多的時候
就可能就跌了
你今天這些東西喔
基本上不會有分析師跟你講這些東西
因為很多人都不懂
所以你聽不懂沒關係
你多看幾次
我看你講這些東西
你在蘋果你本來要9000萬
你本來
你要預計要賣9000萬支手機嘛
假設就是每支手機
一條記憶體
假設啦
9000萬條記憶體
你現在只賣到7000萬條
因為手機只賣7000萬支
多了2000萬支怎麼辦
拿回去賣啊
拿回去賣怎麼辦
會不會變沙價競爭
記憶體會不會漲價沒那麼兇
那這記憶體會不會去影響
三星海利市
會那生意想利是又影響韓國股市嘛
影響韓國股市又影響台灣股市
又影響假的股市
就這麼簡單
講很簡單啦
但我剛才講幾分鐘了
也講了快八九分鐘
一般分析師不會跟你講這些啊
拜託你剛才這前十分鐘
你可以看兩次三次
所以這是好玩
這市場還在吸收衝擊這一塊
AI的好可以去cover
我現在我產品漲價的痛嗎
然後我產品漲價
造成我那一塊營收下滑是這樣能不能懂OK嗎大概懂了吧我們看一下你的覺好不好那可是這個是不是缺點理論上我覺得這一兩個禮拜會比較難做
因為市場上還是吸收衝擊
就如同那時候軟體股
哇 AI讓很多軟體股崩盤的
Adobe這些軟體股都崩盤
為什麼
因為我以後不需要軟體股
我直接就寫成這個
Enthopic直接寫成這個就好了
我不需要這些軟體公司
所以大家是吸收衝擊
可是到最後吸收完這些衝擊以後
納斯達克照樣創新高
可是需要一段時間啊
他說你衝擊兩三個禮拜到一個月啊
是
可是這一段時間
就是你要買股票的時間
只是如果一個分析師什麼都不懂
叫你買買買
那是害到你
可是我懂
你去想想看我的邏輯有沒有錯
想久你就會崇拜我了好不好
OK
來
這跟大家講
來來
今天如果佔一萬人
我禮拜一一定千千嘛
來看一下
今天有機會八九千了嘛
有沒有機會
禮拜五都比較少人喔
這折壓力很大
還好還好
真的還好
我因為我很多股票賺很多
只是在想說要不要賣而已
OK嗎
來
這個拿起來
我就說好買300一下看不到了
這個
我今天算了
我不要看一些無聊留言
記不記得我之前有人說600以下
才今天也看不到
我大概被笑了大概半年到一年吧
後來都是我笑的那些人
好不好
我還是覺得紅海300以下可能看不到
那要一段時間
先跟大家講
好不好
OK
說要懂我的邏輯喔
OK嗎
來
起來鼓今天魂灼灼 黑通通
好不好
希望今天龍之遇為大景
來 先跟大家講
同百事我可以入場
原因上可以
就我講的
那你要注意一件事情
就是你要買
有些股票不要馬上買
因為我講的
來 我講的
這一波修正
就時間軸而言
需要一到兩個禮拜
大家要吸收
因為接下來可能一些利空
比如說我平板是不是
出來的時候
第一消息一定
接下來還會有消息
注意我的預告
蘋果平板賣不好
當然賣的好機率很低
賣不好又是大家怎麼辦
蘋果股價在跌
他還在吸收這個衝擊
蘋果平常賣不好
你懂我意思嗎
你自己看這個價格來看
我做了一些AI圖
可是我看到AI真的不是胖胖
就是股市好玩的地方
你看一下
我剛講這個價錢嘛對不對
最誇張的是25萬的MacBook Pro
25萬台幣變35萬台幣
漲幅高達40%
對不對
一台底電25萬就很扯
變35萬
真的
你看14寸的MacBook Pro
我見什麼大舌頭
好 沒關係啦
這個是最頂配的
很誇張
什麼8TB什麼的
74,900到84,900加1萬
好不好
所以越平價的
你們看到基本上都漲到7000塊
你們用手機基本上都漲7000塊
趕快記得一件事
趕快去買舊手機好不好
如果你今年沒有打算換機的話
好不好
OK
所以今年你覺得什麼
17、18、19跟你在說沒有什麼差的話
那你趕快就現在換
因為等到9月份的時候
你就買不到救手機了
一公布以後就不給你救手機了
OK嗎
那看價格那麼多
一定會影響這些東西
那你看啊
庫克形容說
百年遇遇的洪災啊
加40年生涯中
從外面見過如此劇烈
有沒有看到
iPhone 18大家預估大概涨8000多
動輒破萬元
這應該是會買高階的
就是AI需求
最主要是低論跟內的成本
AI加劇台韓K型分化
为什么
金银股家有做股票的嘛
对不对
有台积电员工
联发科员工
传统产业一般民生
居外人
所以投资票你越做传统产业
比如说你做
銀建啊
是
船廠啊
台塑啊
這些的
就像三十位公司的
我告訴你
甚至你
有時候航運股啊
你在這邊
長榮 陽明啊
是不是
你只要跟科技股
沒有關係的
跟科技業
投資廟
你都應該買AI股
趁這個行情的時候
買AI股
你看做這麼漂亮的字卡
其實也是AI
怎麼會呢
就是大家還在怕
就我講的一件事
苹果会影响纳斯达克走势
纳斯达克走势又会影响
台湾 日本 韩国走势
那苹果为什么会走势那么烂呢
因为记忆体太贵了
记忆太贵了
记忆太贵到时候
记忆体会变成销量不好
就一般消费者这边的记忆体
销量会不好
那会不会这边多的
这边到时候剩下来多的记忆体
会不会反而去影响
原本要涨价的记忆体
大家还在吸收这个话题
还在吸收这个课题
這需要時間
為什麼需要時間
算不出來
官司懂這一個的人就不多了
你懂不懂
所以一開始大家還在吸收
還在慢慢跌 慢慢跌 慢慢跌
今天美國股市可能還是會跌
可能
因為它還在吸收
我講的是什麼
今天美國科技股還在跌
那好玩第二個問題
我不是剛才說嗎
請問你
會不會引發通膨
會引發科技通膨
科技通膨可能會壓
科技股一陣子
但不會引發科技通膨
它佔CPI的數據好像非常低
這但通膨不是一個統計資料
你知道為什麼這些科技產品
佔通膨的數據非常低嗎
第一個 公視
那公視為什麼這樣子
因為實際上你買這些科技產品
你不是必需
是
房租我是必需嘛
對
石油我是必需啊
油價我是必需
為什麼
因為就美國人員
他是每天要通車啊
對
所以科技我
問你啊
三年換一次手機
跟四年換一次手機有什麼差別
都還跑得中
你懂嗎
對
所以它佔通膨的公式本來就很低
實際上因為本來就不需要那麼高
所以它不會影響
怎麼樣
它不會影響通膨數據
既然不會影響通膨數據
不會影響那麼多
那就不會造成廢的主席
去升級 去壓卡股市
最好的證明是什麼
來看一下喔
你看久就知道
哲哲的邏輯跟人家不一樣
昨天有沒有看到
道瓊指數漲來疊的
是漲的
S&P500也是漲的
請金金以後要給我S&P500
好像小漲小疊
就在平板附近
道瓊指數是漲的有沒有看到
這是什麼時候
OK
道瓊指數是漲的
是跟大家講的
真的懂嗎
好不好
看一下數據
我看一下數據
認問一下
怕有錯
沒有關係
好 那這個不重要啦
只是我要告訴大家
道琼指數跟納斯達克指數
都至少在平盤附近或之上
這就是說明什麼
說明了它並不影響通膨
為什麼
因為如果影響通膨
市場預期這個科技業的漲價
記憶體的漲價會影響通膨公市
會影響通膨數據的話
那第一件事情
股市會全面下殺
沒錯吧
是
因為資金撤
因為一升起的話
資金會撤回
從股市中撤回
會放到定存之類的
那這個時候
是不是只有科技股跌而已
會是全面的四大指數都跌
贊同我邏輯嗎 好不好
全面嗎
嗯 全面
可是現在沒有啊
因為我剛才講的是
它不影響通膨
聽得懂我來說什麼嗎
我們看一下
看一下 我看一下
所以我昨天看的是
小道琼跟小納斯達克了
等我一下
對 S&P500是在平盤
跌0.01%
那影響不多啊
好不好
這是我講的
來
所以這間邏輯有比較聽得懂嗎
那美元走強影響台股
我覺得你用美元走強影響台股
我覺得這個是
這個叫做
其實我跟你講
你們講美元走強影響台股
或講說美國股市下跌影響台股
韓國股市影響台股
這都是墜落的想法
為什麼
這叫做
你用結果來嘻嘻
表示一個結果
這就是為什麼70%的賞物
有些不要說70%
部分賞物看不出來
我跟一般賞物的差別
我是說真的 不是我在臭美
所以為什麼很多
我的會員很多是工程師
醫生等級的
因為他們比較喜歡邏輯好的分析師
你不用結果去解釋另外一個結果
那是沒有意義的
你懂嗎
有時候股台股崩了
基本上怎麼樣
台幣就會扁了
亞洲股市幣值就會扁了
亞洲股市幣值扁了
相對於美元就會漲了
就這麼簡單你懂嘛
好不好 OK嗎
來我跟你講
古神我是你會遠
可以問經濟什麼呢
經濟我現在應該沒有買吧
來
反果文藝沒錯
直播人數6000up
好不好
美觀真的是
廢辦是美觀在成
對的對的
對的廢辦是美觀在成
來
這個節目很精彩
今天拜託你多看兩次
今天節目真的很精彩
這是很重要的邏輯
不會有人跟你講這些東西
我認為一般的分析師沒有這個sense
絕對沒有我剛才講的sense
這個知道幾十年經驗加邏輯好
所以市場還在吸收這個衝擊的
AI
記憶體
AI的利多
記憶體漲價的利多
這一塊
是利多
但不知道能撐多久
已經是一個Question Mark了
已經是問號
那因為漲價而造成
終端的消費者的需求減少
那這邊需求減少
記憶體就減少了
那這個是利空
還有一件事忘記跟你講的
那蘋果會投資AI
微軟也會投資AI
Xbox漲價1萬元
當然其實人家這是誇張的新聞
大概漲價大概100到150美元
大概就是3000多到5000
那是跟一開始比漲1萬元
好不重要
Xbox漲價1萬元
問你啊
它佔
它也是Xbox
它也是微軟的一個重要營收
大概佔比了8%
還算可以的
可是我是要告訴你
那如果這一塊到時候也賣不好
會不會
我會點什麼
如果我這家企業營收沒有那麼好了
是不是有可能會減少AI投資
是
所以大家還在吸收這個衝擊
懂不懂
我蘋果我東西賣不好
我怎麼去投資AI
我微軟東西賣不好
我怎麼投資AI
你知道嗎
understand
這樣懂我的邏輯吧
所以整整一切的一切
我預告在前面
所以其實到最後大家發現
有影響但影響不多
这个时候股质才会开始涨
所以这一个礼拜大家还在吸收
这跟大家讲
大家在吸收
所以我要讲这些东西OK吗
慢慢的来讲这些东西
所以逻辑很重要
来
群联怎么看
群联记忆体的东西
来
可是记忆体我要告诉大家
最該影響這一塊
就NAC
為什麼我說NAC比較多
來 我先跟大家講哪一件事
但NAC不是最該跌
因為昨天美款也是很強
最該跌的是
華星科跟
就被動元件這一塊
為什麼被動元件這一塊
沒有理由
你說穿
你去問業界每一件事情
你看現在CPU不是也跌很慘嗎
CPU
拜託
CPU要做也不是台灣的小產商做
所以會被大產通知
CPU是趨勢
跟你買的CPU的股票
跟之前很多人推薦的CPU股票
未来会赚钱是两回事
可是股价先给你涨个几百元
这对吗
逻辑完全不对
主力要炒就主力要炒
我没差
我看不过这一切
我也不要去攻击别人
我也不会讲哪一种股票
逻辑要重要
逻辑正确
你看整个讲话有时候很拽
但是还是有人看我节目
为什么
因为我就是站在对的一边
我的逻辑基本上你不会去挑剔它
很难去挑剔我的逻辑那我也告訴你國際有什麼不應該這樣國際有什亂跌那被動元件本來就不是技術最難的你在騙大家我不是說國際騙大家
我是說現在股價在把他硬啊拉來的一些
中時或大戶
當然也沒有人家賺很多
我不知道怎麼想
我要講的
我也不要去批評人家
我要講的是最主要的原因是
長那麼多了
回彈正常
就像環球金大家也覺得長很多
環球金也是一樣一件事來
手機這一塊有很多成熟製程
你不要看只有先進製程跟台積電買
也很多成熟製程你知道嗎
是
所以大家會覺得成熟製程會不會影響到
比如說我世界先進嘛
我不需要成熟製程那麼多嘛對不對
那世界先進影響到以後怎麼辦
會不會影響到環球基金這一塊
你知道嗎
這種意思嗎
懂
我覺得最後
我有做過一個研究統計
所以我看過一些文獻
基本上漲價會影響短期的消費
中期消費不會
如果是一起展的話
你聽懂嗎
那會不會一起展
會啊
你到時候發現手機都漲價
你聽懂還說什麼
懂
那你就會吸收它
你就會接收它
就影響
初期會影響很大
中期影響不大
也會影響很大不大
可是大家很怕是
再漲下去怎麼辦
再漲下去就會影響很大
好不好
所以大家還在吸收這個衝擊
還在算這個
到底影響營收多少
影響EPS多少
而不要說
而不要說啦
我剛剛問我這一段
如果不是我講的話
基本上了解這一段的人不到1%
那了解這一段的人不到1%
然後重點是這一段人裡面
假設一萬一百萬個人
可能就一萬人知道我這一家講什麼
可是一萬人裡面基本上沒有什麼人
應該是沒有人
算不出來
短期內算不出來衝擊多少
這就是股市跌的原因
懂不懂
算不出來衝擊到底
衝擊會不會影響這個其他的利多
所以要先跌再說
可是我跟你講
拉回是買點
因為就一般的文...
就這樣
什麼
我舉個最簡單嘛
那個美伊戰爭之前是不是先跌
對
然後不是先跌
跌了以後怎麼樣
欸
還是怎麼樣
美伊戰爭打更兇啊
是
油價跌更兇喔
要毀滅地...
要毀滅它
把伊朗文明整個從世界上消失喔
川普講這種話喔
結果最後呢
不好意思
油價再怎麼跌 股市照漲
當股市接受這個衝擊
算出來好像已經利空動畫
它就會漲
這需要一兩個禮拜的時間
你聽得懂嗎
因為這個才利空
快的話一個禮拜算快了
算快了
所以禮拜一禮
可是我跟你講
可是一個禮拜的時間
如果一個禮拜的時間就吸收完畢了
那不是下週都是買跌
當然有運氣好的老師跟我說
我跌拉回就買 拉回就買
你要看這種節目你自己看
你懂不懂
因為是有可能一個禮拜
混水摸魚摸到魚
可是邏輯對才重點
邏輯不對
混水摸魚摸到最後一次
會摸到大白鯊
很恐怖
所以我跟你講我的判斷是
最後你會發現利多大於利空
AI是一個趨勢
你告訴我
我只要告訴你這件事情就好了
光是這K型這些塊
這些都是我們用AI做的
你看看
這個呢
做的很漂亮
AI做的
做的
我們做的就特別漂亮
你看一般你的投顧沒辦法
只有某個投顧我們就是比較堅強
來 我跟大家
AI加劇台含K型瘋狂有沒有
這就是一個K
請問你
AI科技精英跟傳統產業有沒有
這是K字有沒有
兩極化的意思
我請問你
你一般人
你不要說一般人
就像頂尖的設計師
能做出來這些嗎
很難啦
那你能再一分鐘做出來嗎
不可能啦
這基本上你只要灌資料給他
一分鐘就可以做完了
你扯不扯
真的很厲害
一分鐘
K型是什麼
你看
他告訴你哇
新竹房價三翻倍
我聽到一瓶九幾萬的
我還記得2020年
我很多的工程師的朋友說
哇 新竹房子很便宜
一坪二幾萬啊
現在變一坪九十幾萬
真的啊
才二十幾萬
2019年 二十幾萬啊
你去問一下可以留言啊
2019年啊
疫情前啊
真的
疫情的時候也是差不多
更便宜
那時候八五二十三點的時候
男孩也是一樣啊
你看啊
所以這個男孩現在
就是K型的挑戰
這個我要講說
這告訴你說
現在就是兩個人生
你是工程師
你不是工程師
你更要投資AI
你是工程師
你也要投資AI
為什麼
因為AI如果取代你怎麼辦
你不是工程師
你更要投資AI
為什麼
因為你沒有其他賺錢的方式
更好的方式
的確是
好來
所以AI加劇
經濟不平等
可是社會上
我跟你講沒有辦法
不會有人可憐你
你得自己想辦法
你今天看我的節目
其實你就是邁向成功的方式
你不要參加我會員
可是你可以鎖定
一直鎖定我的節目
好不好
這是跟大家講好不好
你看這AI
因為這邊還有點錯字有沒有
是喔 下次不要出現這字
強勁
音樂不錯了啦對不對
是
音樂不錯了啦你看
好啦
Google人才大師
這個就不用講了
那今天是6月嘛對不對
接下來摩台結算
7月有那個製造業的API
這個還好還好
重點是這一塊
市場在吸收好不好
來
那外資呢
三大法人外資的事啊
能不能聽我的東西
給我看一下三大法人
今天空單
有點回補了
來
那很多人說
嘖嘖
沒事
在這邊來
來來我們看一下
這個外資
我們今天看一下看一下
講話同時看一下
展275點
今天有點殺過頭
因為本來正價差
已經差點變逆價差
你知道嗎
我看一下 沒錯已經變逆價
所以展上去了
疊那麼多 展一下去
很正常
好不好 很正常
可是我覺得要一個禮拜吸收
我覺得差不多一個禮拜
三大法人還沒出來
正價所最近比較晚
很少 以前2點55分出來
等一下如果三大法人
四遙或者是其他的賞務朋友們
也麻煩跟我們講一下好不好
可是我還是要告訴大家
我覺得大家在西州是衝擊
可是最後會驗證我說法是對的
AI的利多會大於漲價的利空
還是上去
所以當然我也可以簡單一句話說
拉回就是買
可是最low
因為今天是真的發生一些大事件
因為那個漲得真的滿誇張的
真的
網路上你看臉書都會覺得很誇張
好 來
那我們來看一下
來
來 所以我要講說
鴻海
第一期會影響到
好 會影響到
短期一定會影響到
今天iPhone看起來賣不好的機率比較高一點點
因為長太多了
可是
假設啦
我覺得EPS你說20塊
影響到18塊
老師沒有
這邊會不會本益比太低啊
或者維持20塊
你12倍本益比是幹什麼
真的喔
這都太低了
假設就18塊好了
EPS降低18塊
我說假設啦
248除占18塊
13倍本益比都很低啊
有沒有
拉尾轟海的过程中你要买
好不好
这边不是让你去悲伤的时候
5347世界先进也是一样
为什么一样
请问你他好不容易创新高了
要不是今天崩盘
是不是不然世界先进
其实是还会在涨
所以今天世界先进
我觉得你可以趁这一两天的时候
买进股票
那有些股票
那世界先进的善有谁
环球金
环球金我看一下什么时候
是喔
写一下环球金什么时候
那个
儲置結束
剛剛給我
花樣已經儲置結束後就拉起來了
你還記得一件事
有沒有看到
每一次儲置的時候見低點
為什麼只能看儲置見低點
這邊是不是亮說
對
見個低點
什麼
為什麼亮說見低點
因為儲置的時候有賣壓
有沒有看到亮說
是不是
是 真的
見低點有沒有看到
那現在亮說呢
又見低點
我不知道會再下去
我只知道越點你越要買
理論上不可能跌破730
理論上來說
至少這一個處置期間
所以投資表
就是跟大家講是說
在這邊拉回要買
我不是很難去猜這個對提點
所以你說這拉起來
我覺得你也不要看這樣的漲幅
重點是要看網上的股市
怎麼去算這一塊
好不好 OK嗎
這個會不會是Tim Cook 最後的報酬
因為強迫被退休了
你那種強迫被退休了
不是對啦 我這是開玩笑啦
強迫被退休喔
然後我不高興我搞砸蘋果
這個是開玩笑的
所以股票馬上跟大家講這些東西
來來
那融資間
我不去預測融資
我越見融資都消消耶
智元
我覺得今天也跌
這跟智元沒有什麼關係
像這種股票其實本來要創新高
這間跌的就可以買
我反而想要買智元跟世界先進再加碼
我是認真的
好不好
那投資長你剛才說過了
2327的國巨
你怎麼看
國巨
怎麼樣
國巨這些股票
漲太多了
那好
我問你
漲太多了你就該走
沒有錯
那我問你一件事
你會想問我一件事
2454聯發科呢
聯發科我有沒有走
我之前有跟你講過
跌波失先緣我考慮走
因為怎麼樣我都賺100%以上
那我今天有沒有走
文章有沒有寫
我先賣個關子好不好
補助長先不能說
不講 今天打算不講啦
可是我有講過跌破四千元我要走
這句話是代表怎麼走
聽起來好像是
不重要
反正我利於不敗之地
如果就算我今天走
我怎麼樣賺一百多%
這就是低基期的好處
我讓會員股票就是賣在低基期
你怎麼賣到4970
那都是老頭顧
每天可以胡扯你做的事情
我沒有辦法做這種事情
我確定了這邊
跌破這底部了
你該走就走
那有沒有走
我有暗示你
聽不懂我也沒辦法
因為我不
不需要講那麼清楚
這跟大家講
好不好
你看
簡訊會員
從我報到尾到現在
一個口令一個動作
還是賺滿多
有沒有看到
折加油
這個行情不會很快就
很快
很快這個利空就會消化
但你不要看今天的
今天一天不夠
除非連續兩天
美國股市都很極度的上漲
就是差不多都漲差不多
只要兩天加起來
我覺得大概1.8%到2%就夠了
就代表這個漲價的利空
已經怎麼樣結束了
好不好
這是跟大家講
聯發科我不是不看好
就跟國具我沒有說不看好
可是國具300元國具跟1000元的國具
就是有差嘛
你聽得懂嗎
聽得懂
300元的國具跟1000元國具有差嘛
就像聯發科不是不好嘛
我買的時候1300
1400 1500
1400-1500左右
現在來個最高的4900
我幹嘛啊
看外資報告給你寫個6000多
是幹什麼啦
我問你今天是啦
我是不是說講後年的EPS很負責任
是
今天蘋果來個漲價
你叫同心估算的
對景氣的影響的
你過來個後年EPS幹什麼
你怎麼知道後年會不會被
單職被搶走
我們講過
有喔
有時候我問
不屑有些外資的報告
我不要講哪一家啦
我不要講誰的名字
講那些都沒有意義
你知道嗎
譬如說你預估不要預估到後年去
我覺得很不...
除非你告訴我
像台積電預估到後你還有機會
因為技術領先嘛
聯發哥你哪有時候技術非常領先啊
是
你可能被人家砍一砍架
又被人家搶走了你懂不懂
TPO晶片
博通能做 聯發哥能做
代表別人也能做
代表還有原本的產商
可以把你搶回來
博通可以把你搶回來
你的叮噹從Google手上
OK嗎 但懂我還說什麼嗎
好不好
記得我說的這些東西邏輯
那我們來看有些股票
其實
這個也許股票有錢一件事
來 還有早盤在漲的股票
早盤就是跌滿多的
反正早盤在漲欸
它不像世界先進欸
早盤就跌有沒有看到沒錯吧反正是早盤在漲所以早盤在漲的股票你也可以考慮買還有跌很深比如說我今天就是本來要創新高跌停板的股票像世間先進
快跌停板的股票
或是四元
有沒有看到
要嘛就很極端
跌很深
要嘛就另外一種
很看跌
這兩個都是好股票
知不知道
2376技嘉
技嘉其實是到最後才殺去
不然也沒有那麼兇
看紀錄限定最近都有點弱
好不好
都有點像鴻海
因為本來就是很多人
把他當作那種老AI的族群
好不好
那微星我就覺得最可惜
因為他根本沒漲
所以你看他比較看跌
有沒有
所以微星有機會噴
沒錯吧
你聽看
他是到最後一盤的殺
對
他今天還能漲的股票算很厲害
是不是
今天還能漲的股票算很厲害
真的
只是自選股裡面
現在是今天十膽
裡面有八膽是跌
可是你不要擔心
就說我講的
危機是轉機
100個老師裡面
今天大概99個月長
危機是轉機
拉回就是買
老掉重彈
但是我的邏輯不一樣
我覺得吸收這個話題
吸收這個漲價的衝擊
我覺得時間一到兩週內
那這一到兩週就是你一個買點
好不好
越拉越長越好
那代表鐵很兇
是
你也不要去抓最低點
你就是有錢就買點
有錢就買點
姊姊我已經買滿了
買滿就放著吧
因為我們大
不管說百分之百
但我們大多數的會員進場的成本
都是很低的
好不好
就講今天聯發課就算賣掉了
你還是
上100多%啊
是啊 你還是上100多%啊
37是精彩啊
你看這幾天漲我也不敢去追啊
拉回是不是就可以買了
拉回我就想買了喔
好不好
那我問你一件事啊
今天11800點啊
是不是
你拿00661
不是
反正就是你来买个期货
你可能今天就停损了
你就出掉了
你懂我说吗
你今天期货跌了1000多点嘛
对不对
你可能今天停损了
你就出掉
真是破产了
因为你用杠杆
因为你用期货
你用类似杠杆
你可能跌1万点就拜拜
你不要用杠杆的
基本上你可以活得好好的
当你用杠杆的时候
你就是在赌大赌小而已
不是賭大跟小
是賭的多還是賭的少而已
這個跟大家講
所以記得我的邏輯
一切就在前面
我看到什麼股票
慢慢講
今天今天是
所以
次要來幫我記一下
今天比強中比較強的股票
國具你看
你開盤連漲都沒有漲
微星居然有
嚇死我
要嘛就是大跌的股票
要嘛跌停的股票
大跌的股票
要嘛就是很抗跌的股票
這兩種OK嗎
來來
所以我們看一下三大法人
來看一下
黃永青到下週五又來了
那黃永青是不是有可能
下週三下週四要拉暫停了
黃永青是非戰之最人
你看喔
你只要2000多這樣就可以殺到點停板
20億的成交量
之前有時候都100億以上的成交量
所以非戰之最好
這三大法人還沒出來喔
是假的真的喔
壞掉了是不是
看起來今天是有可能13歲大賣超
有可能喔
真的喔
我覺得3.18分嘛
我覺得超過1800億喔
等一下
看你這樣真的預測能力對不對
好不好
讀一下
我敢讀耶
我們看一下
看一下台股走勢图
因為今天台股走勢
是第三大跌點嘛
加上台幣的貶值
台幣今天貶值
貶不多啦
貶0.14
貶那個不多不多
那個0.4角
可是台幣的貶值
加上證交所這麼晚算出來
加上台灣股市今天大跌
1683點
我認為今天外資的確有可能賣超
1800億
史上最大賣超
好歹有1000億
賭了
跟你們賭了
好不好
你看我是考慮很多數據
從我講話的時候
就知道我邏輯跟人家不太一樣
所以為什麼我跟人家賭的時候
之前賭雞排我也賭贏了
就是一個月內要攢1000點
等同於
現在一個月內要漲差不多5000點
一個月內
那時候我在賭這個事情
4000多點
一個月內漲4000多點
現在3.39分
跟你們小賭一下
這賭是名譽的問題
有沒有
現在下午3.49分
這要所數據還沒出來嘛
對不對
會不會馬上被打臉
思雅說3.18分有沒有到
3.18分還沒有
好不好
我直接賭了
今天賣時尚最大賣超
外資時尚最大賣超
1800億以上
OK
直接就敢預測
一切一切遇到前面
像昨天不准不了解
我說哲哲你不准
我昨天有前提說
美國股市不要給我亂搞
美國股市給我亂搞
那怎麼辦
對不對
美國股市不要亂搞的話
苹果今天不要出這個巴拉價格
亂攢一通的話
也不會影響到
美國股市跟韓國股市
你不影響到美國股市
韓國股市韓國股市今天有攢
昨天的確是在攢
對不對
沒錯吧
是
我剛剛讀什麼
就讀了
讀什麼
沒有啦 賭名譽就好了
要賭什麼
這沒必要吧
賭雞排嗎
不用啦
賭很大耶
1800億這樣賭很大
就一般的生意來講的話
是那個大概只有三四成而已耶
可是我覺得我敢賭
我就覺得生意應該有八成啦
好不好
賭一台救護車
買啦 我敢捐救護車而已啦
欸一來五百萬你們不要這樣子好不好
我有乾捐好不好
你們真的很愛跟我賭欸
我賭了多
我就知道你們要說這個
我賭名譽而已好不好
我覺得我贏啦
但我不想因為這種事
賭個
我賭歷史最大賣超
跟你賭個救護車
我說話是要算話的欸
來看一下好不好
捐救護車
桃園市政府
我看對不對
他喊那個
這個沒有辦法騙人
這個傳出去
這是偽照文書欸好不好
郭總統先生有沒有看到
有沒有捐什麼
捐本府消防車
這是折衡啦
折衡啦
本府消防車救護車一定要看到
市府同意並謝謝我
OK嗎
市長
好不好
這跟藍跟綠沒有關係
反正我要
我人生抱負要捐很多台
之後什麼顏色都會有
你不用擔心好不好
希望大家不要介意
捐救護車
乾捐人
不要再賭救護車了可以嗎
還有我講話直
還有我講話結結巴巴
1431喔
幸好沒躲喔
我剛才有說至少1000億啊
對不對
那14314
歷史第二大
這個叫做
這叫做60分
60分
沒有錯吧 60分
是
14314是不是歷史第二大
是喔
來來
一麥超一麥
我說怎麼樣都有1100啊
沒錯啊
來
那是不是
是不是第一次第二大
是喔 我記得第二大吧
第一大是昨天1774嘛
然後
好像第二大是
之前第二大是
1400還是1200
好不好
OK
這台幣貶的不夠多啦
對…
這台幣貶的不夠多是結果啦
如果台幣貶更多
那更有信心
好不好
差點有雞排吃
幸好幸好
可是我剛剛講喔
至少怎麼樣都1000億喔
好不好
只能說明天一定漲
我問他說一定漲
封鎖他
你理我說一定漲嗎
沒有啊
你們看一下我講話的內容
我基本上我講話
不會亂留把柄給你們的
好不好
對就對就錯了就錯了
有啦有一次啦
後我告訴你美債我要賺兩千萬才走
不小心講錯話了
很激動
第三大是1208
所以沒錯啦
所以第二大啊
好不好
整個意思是不會升息嘛
你剛才講說科技通膨嘛
今年會升息
Fatbatch今年會升息
但不會因為
那個電子產品的iPhone
雖然你們會看YouTube的人
都比較年輕的
不會因為iPhone漲價長那麼誇張
iPad漲價長那麼誇張
而影響通膨數據
進而升息
要升息也不是因為科技產品
漲價而升息
這樣懂嗎
OK
這更大
差不多大家不要太嚴格
對 我覺得至少剛才有60分吧
折分機是可以用連電嗎
連電跟環球機一樣啦好不好
只是會換新的蘋果手機
會喔 我會換喔
我會換折疊手機好不好
OK嗎
我換折疊手機
但是
可是折疊手機我現在很習慣你知道嗎
我現在習慣
比如說有時候
APP我按進去的時候對
還可以再用Face ID
就把握這程式
你不想讓人家亂點
我怕以後
折疊手機沒有Face ID
就是沒有用
用Face ID
用臉部的辨識來看的話
我覺得比較沒有隱私感
所以我就考慮
我說不定折疊手機也會買
然後iPhone
你說最新是什麼
今年最新是什麼
小孩18是不是
iPhone 18我也會買
會買啦
折會買的 又不是沒有錢
好不好
這更大
該買的時候買 而且是投資啊
因為有可能折疊手機賣的好
那我買個平蓋股
讓會員賺更多啊
是不是
OK
來來
折疊了
星星呢 什麼
我不知道 你今天好嗨喔
今天人好多
我看一下 7000多人嗎
這個是蠻蠢的喔
出來了
3點22分
賣1430億
歷史第二大
雖不中 亦不原已 好不好
OK嗎
所以今天好玩的跟大家賭一下
好不好
沒有完全賭對
就知道我一切都預告在前面
好不好
來 我們來跟大家講
所以
可是我要告訴大家
這個利多會大於利空
這邊拉回要買
雖然給你這個結論
可是我的過程是很精彩
拜託你等一下回去重看一下
好不好
但自然在吸收這個衝擊
產價衝擊
所以這些股票
然後有人說
沒關係 聯電怎麼看
我剛才給大家看一下
你那個事情
一樣意思嘛
你環球金都
你世界先進
環球金都快跌停了
年年不會受影響嘛
一定會嘛
因為蘋果還是這種成熟製程
好不好
我要講練一次
今天重點來
1億本來要創新高
因為今天大跌
這兩天大跌被拉回的股票
比如說環球金
是
比如說智源
環球金還好
環球金休息一陣子
休息一陣子
就是不是這一兩天的事
比如說世界先進智源
你就可以買
本來要創新高不要拉回
第二個
你今天盤中還在漲的股票
彈訓就厲害了喔
朋友那場喔
阿那個微星也厲害喔
呵呵
可是微星最爛的是
它就是比較牛皮啦
我們比較牛皮啦
微星比較
先看一下
可是至少盤中有漲的股票
就是好股票
或盤中跌很兇
大跌
可是本來要串心高
那也是好股票
你要記得老天送給你的禮物好不好
這個一切切則
預告一切片
現在幾分了
50我要結束了好不好
今天節目很精彩喔
你記得喔
上一次賺最多的是什麼
來啦
我問你件事啦
4月的時候
不是說禮拜一見低點嗎
有沒有印象
有
今天就要環球金好了
今天丟到930
我730買了
丟到930你還算是20% 30%
有什麼不對
你聽懂嗎
欸 最初是賺20% 30%欸
你每一次拉回都是買點
最近每一次拉回都買點
你不趁拉回的時候加入會員
你每次都趁台股創新高的時候加入會員
你當然會覺得很煩躁啊
所以你去想看
你要怎麼知道
想對就我今天邏輯很對
我們是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
自己看清楚
唯一百萬粉絲的好不好
132萬訂閱者
這想清楚想明白
歡迎留言下去
0806-8085
或加有LINE私訊我
不論對我有錯者
直接一切一切預告前面
去香港的影片
指南粉絲
也預祝各位能夠收到錢
拜拜
我愛你們
判斷、省慎評估並自負投資風險